así después hay dos personas más que
fueron imputados que estaban imputados
el día de hoy por una parte se trata de
tierra de los dos abogado de nicolas
sarkozy y también el ex magistrado river
libia ambos también fueron encontrados
culpables recibieron también una
sentencia de tres años de cárcel con ese
sus dos años
ese año firmé perdón y hay que saber que
para trabajado sobre el abogado de
nicolasa judío hay algo más que hay en
esta pena y esa es una prohibición de
cinco años de ejercer el derecho a
partir de ahora hay que saber que al
psoe que es uno de los abogados más
prestigiosos y más reconocidos que hay
en el país y como usted bien lo decía
bueno pues el tribunal consideró que
había suficientes indicios suficientes
pruebas de que hubo un pacto de
corrupción entre estas tres personas que
además estaban al tanto de lo que
estaban haciendo que porque no solamente
pues se trata se trata de más de tres
abogados porque sarkozy es abogado de
profesión y quienes además según este
tribunal pues es un garante de la
independencia de la justicia ya que se
trata de un
presidente de la república además de
esto la corte o este tribunal perdón
consideró que era algo muy importante
decir que se había vulnerado la
confianza pública la confianza en la
justicia pues se trató de manipular una
decisión de la corte de casación para
que fallara a favor de intereses
personales y que por eso la respuesta de
este tribunal la respuesta penal tenía
que ser una respuesta firme ahora
natalia que otros procesos están
abiertos contra el exmandatario
bueno pues digamos que hay dos procesos
más uno de ellos que de hecho comienza
dentro de 15 días nicolas sarkozy que
salió muy rápido de este tribunal una
vez se suspendió la sesión pero así de
rápido como se fue pues así de rápido
tendrá que volver ante la justicia
dentro de 15 días como bien les decía
comienza a este caso que es el conocido
aquí en francia como vigma lyon se trata
sobre las cuentas de campaña de su
campaña de reelección en el 2012 digamos
que se no se sospecha pues que esta
empresa que se encargaba de su campaña
que es la empresa llamada big mal yo no
habría maquillado los informes para
tapar o para esconder que se habían ha
pasado los topes de campaña de hasta más
de 20 millones de euros y el otro el
proceso que por ahora no tiene fecha
pero cuya digamos las investigaciones
comenzaron en 2013 pues tiene que ver
con su campaña de 2007 y la financiación
de esa campaña que al parecer habría
sido por de dinero se habría venido
dinero
el régimen libio de muamar kadhafi pero
este proceso ha tenido muchísimos
problemas no solamente porque hacía una
investigación muy larga sino porque a
finales del año pasado uno de los
testigos claves que habían dicho que
había entregado maletas con dinero a
claude juncker al secretario a nicolas
sarkozy pero se retractó de estas de
estas declaraciones así que es un
proceso que lleva mucho más tiempo por
ahora ese juicio no tiene una fecha de
inicio
natalia por último que viene para el ex
presidente sarkozy y que planea su
defensa
pues la verdad es que una vez se terminó
esta esta audiencia del día de hoy sus
abogados no dieron ningún tipo de
declaraciones a la prensa como les había
dicho el presidente salió muy rápido de
el tribunal pero se espera que pues
apple en esta decisión y en caso de
apelar pues digamos que esto hace que
estas penas esta condena digamos quede
suspendida sobre todo porque también los
intereses políticos cuando en este
momento en francia se comienza a hablar
o se comienzan a digamos calentar
motores para decir de una manera arcaica
en la campaña presidencial pues habrá
elección presidencial en 2022 y nicolas
sarkozy siempre aparece como esa figura
que podría de nuevo fuese entrar a
pelear la de manuel ama con la
presidencia de 2022 por ahora es muy
probable que se apele esta decisión aquí
esto va a ser ante otro tribunal y luego
también incluso podrían apelar la
decisión de ese tribunal si no les es
favorable pero esta vez sería ante la
corte de casación
que es la que puede confirmar o cambiar
está este veredicto así es natalia
muchísimas gracias por toda esta
información en desarrollo por supuesto
muy pendientes